this is a production of cornell
university
so first and foremost i want to welcome
you all to the first ever agroforesee
session at the empire state producers
expo
so thank you all for being here for
making a little bit of history
it's really great to have you
and i want to start things off
by giving an acknowledgement of
the land that is currently called new
york state and i am currently in uh
what's known as ithaca new york which is
gaegohono territory
and um
coming you know i'm affiliated with
cornell university
and cornwall university is located on
the traditional homelands of the gaia
gohono which who are the kyugen nation
the gaia gohono are members of the
nishoni confederacy which is an alliance
of six sovereign nations with a historic
and contemporary presence
on this land
the confederacy precedes the
establishment of cornell university new
york state and the united states of
america
we acknowledge the painful history of
gaga honor dispossession and honor the
ongoing connection of
people
past and present to these lands and
waters
this land acknowledgment that i just
read has been reviewed and approved by
the traditional gai gohan leadership and
in addition to this acknowledgement but
also separate from it it's important to
um acknowledge that cornell's founding
was enabled
in the course of a national genocide by
the sale of almost one million acres of
stolen indigenous land
by way of the moral act of 1862
and to date cornell university has
neither officially acknowledged its
complicity in this nor has it offered
any form of restitution the hundreds of
native communities impacted
i will talk a little bit more about this
in a little bit but also i encourage you
to check out cornell university's
indigenous dispossession website if
you're curious for more information
and i'm just showing here on this map
um what is outlined in purple
is the traditional territories of the
haudenosaunee people
and included here i want to say that
some of the common names that we know
them by such as kuga or seneca onondaga
etc and so again you'll see here um
alternate spellings and
of these of these words um the the names
that you may commonly known
are what they were given um by
english-speaking peoples and and these
the other names that you see
are
um
are what we call endonyms which are the
names they call themselves in their own
language and they are not perfect
spellings these are non-english words
and so um this map is is a work in
progress and also
um you know pronunciation is is not
something i am uh trained in anyway what
i'm trying to say is that these are as
we learn more about cultural competency
it's important to learn uh the names of
the peoples by which they call
themselves
this is how things look today the areas
in purple are the current
um
current territories that are um
that are uh
controlled and uh recognized by the um
by these nations
some of them have been are have been um
exported to other other countries such
as um here wisconsin the united nation
has a territory in wisconsin as well as
canada
as you can see
it's a much much smaller proportion of
land than originally
they were
occupied in
and this is also to say that these these
people are still here and it's important
um
that we acknowledge that and recognize
that and work towards better relations
as as neighbors and occupiers on their
land
as i briefly mentioned earlier coral
university
has a very long history with
with this process and while
by the time that cornell was established
as a university
the haudenosaunee dispossession had
already taken place just by way of
the
new york state government as well as the
government of the united states and the
colonies
however cornell university has
um
has profited and benefited from the sale
of indigenous
land elsewhere and that's what this map
shows mostly um in the midwest as well
as in what is today california and so if
you want to learn more about this it's a
really really fascinating and important
story i recommend going to
landgrabu.org which is where the story
first broke
in march 2020 as well as learning more
about the american indian and indigenous
studies program at cornell university
and how this all really relates to
agroforestry is that
a lot of research is recently coming out
that is
expressing our scientific understanding
of how indigenous
land practices
have shaped
the landscapes that we see today and our
understanding that agroforestry is an
indigenous ingenuity and this evidence
is coming from all over the world and
here i have just a slice of of this
which represents places like the amazon
the pacific northwest and even in parts
of new york state today
um and so everything that you're going
to see in this presentation while we are
continuing to to developing
new um new takes on agroforestry it is
is a technology and a relationship with
the land that is deeply deeply old
um and i think all of our practitioners
and and researchers
have have an understanding of this and
it's something that we wish to highlight
even great uh more greatly and develop
more connections with
agroforestry also has been very uh
recently recognized for its pe for its
contributions um to both the adaptation
and mitigation of climate change
and i'm just going to very quickly
um this this uh this figure comes from
the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change their report that came out in
2019 not the most recent one but very
recent which shows here very quickly the
agroforestry and the um is able to the
darker colors in this in this matrix
here
the darker the color means the more
highly the potential it has been
assessed to have and so it has
agroforestry as one of as a land
management practice
it's assessed to have extremely high
positive impacts on the mitigation and
adaptation of climate change as well as
in terms of combating desertification
land degradation as well as positively
impacting food security and you can also
see it has a very low cost
and ipcc
has given it an estimate of up to about
five and a half billion tons of carbon
dioxide equivalent in terms of the
amount of carbon dioxide equivalent that
it can sequester and so this is really
important the agroforestry is not only
something that can provide food
um but can also
help to
not adapt to a changing climate as well
as help
reduce the risk and exposure to that
and then this is from the most recent
report which just came out
this is in chapter eight
and
it says that in spite of various
benefits of agroforestry the expansion
of existing areas of agroforestry and
the establishment of new agroforestry
systems has remained limited
mainly due to lack of institutional
supports lack of expert support to
ensure adequate management weak capacity
for monitoring and regulation
and a lack of financial support and so
given all this given all this challenge
and promise that both the agroforestry
has i'm really extremely grateful that
agra foreshade has been included in this
um
this expo this year and i'm really
especially grateful to see dr steve
reiners who's with us today
who has been played a huge supportive
role um not only in bringing
uh all of us together but just welcoming
this um this topic into this uh this
expo
and also many thanks to the expo staff
for all of the technical support they
have been giving us
if you're interested in learning more
about my work i focus on growing
nutrients in new york state
you can contact me here my my emails
here sfv42
and you can also follow me on social
media at research is nuts
thank you samantha for that introduction
and for just setting a really nice tone
in your intro there
um i might go over a bit of the similar
similar content but i think i'll just be
kind of building upon what you really
laid out in your introduction
all right well i'm really excited to be
here today and to share a little bit
about the work i do um as samantha said
i work with cornell cooperative
extension in columbia and green counties
at the agroforestry resource center
which is located in greene county the
northern catskills
so um just a quick overview of my talk
i'm just going to briefly go over what
agroforestry is just so i'm not making
any assumptions about uh people's
knowledge
um i'll share
the work that the center does a little
bit of our history
and then a kind of a summary of the
different layers of efforts that we
engage in so highlighting some national
regional and local work
and then sharing a bit about what we do
at a really local level with programming
demonstrations and resource development
okay so first of all um
by i guess usda standards
agroforestry is defined as the
intentional integration of trees and
agriculture
to me um again intentional conservation
goals while building climate resilient
profitable systems
um
so in essence to me all of that
wording really means putting the right
plants or animals um in the right
location for the right reason so letting
the land really guide your management
decisions
and um there's many different forms that
agroforestry can take when combining um
all these different systems so it's been
broken out into these five different
practices or systems
so those would include silver pasture
which we'll hear more about later today
from brett
it also includes wind breaks so using
rows of perennial plants to reduce wind
effects on crops riparian buffers which
can be
fruitful and productive or just
ecologically based
it also includes alley cropping which is
combining perennial and annual
agriculture to
reap the benefits of both
and then it also includes forest farming
which is the kind of world that i mostly
live in
and that is um for farming under the
canopy of an existing for forest
and so as samantha really beautifully
laid out um agroforestry is nothing new
this is really rooted in indigenous
knowledge
or all you know it's also known as
traditional ecological knowledges and
this is something that has been a part
of indigenous culture in
their everyday way of life
for thousands and thousands of years um
and i think it's great to you know be
able to revisit those historical
practices and kind of bring them to
light and so i just had a few examples
of different ways that agroforestry has
existed for for some time um so on the
left here we have
traditional birch bark containers being
made for maple sap
in the center there is blueberry
collection in
a highly managed forest to encourage
that crop to grow
and then on the right here we have a
graphic i mean made by colleen rossier
who works with the yurok and karak
tribes in northern california and has
documented some of their traditional
agroforestry systems by using fire
pruning and other management practices
to produce crops like acorns
huckleberries mushrooms and more and
that's all done both for
you know their own consumption but also
to meet ecological needs
so why
why use agroforestry why why care about
it um and there are just so so many
reasons so i hope to just highlight a
few um
so
in any farming endeavor obviously
economic benefits are important so that
is certainly one of the benefits of
agroforestry but it also comes with
what might be equally important benefits
such as ecological and social
and i have just a kind of quick
comparison it's
overly simplified but it i think it
drives home a really great point um
comparing monoculture systems so just uh
you know one crop in a field to a more
complex system for example an alley
cropping system that has the perennial
trees with annual crops in the middle
and this graph
shows
different benefits of different
practices of those two practices and
where you see the bar the yellow bar
extending higher up towards each of
those benefits
it represents a greater benefit
so if we look um at soil protection for
example in a in a monoculture system
your soil protection is fairly low
almost non-existent whereas in
agroforestry systems it's much higher
due to the consistent coverage
and so if you look around that wheel all
of the spokes on that wheel kind of
represent that in agroforestry systems
those benefits are greater carbon
sequestration water quality protection
habitat enhancement
you'll note though the only place where
the benefits aren't greater is workload
reduction
so as these are intensive and sometimes
complex systems they often require much
more labor up front and then you're able
to reap the benefits of the systems that
you've created and are able to work with
later
and so when you look at land use in new
york state we are a very
heavily forested state um 61 forested in
fact and that kind of breaks up to an
acre per residence which is quite a bit
of forested land
and so like i said before um you know
agroforestry is really about putting the
right the right practice in the right
place and so it's using what the land
has to offer and for for us in new york
we're so lucky to have quite a bit of
forested land to work with
and
i think agroforestry allows us to place
a higher value on that forested land um
you'll note here that i i mentioned 21
of farmland is actually forested and so
instead of you know maybe just paying
taxes on that land or perhaps even
seeing it as a burden or maybe just
integrating you know passive recreation
or pulling firewood there's so much more
that can be done to
enhance the quality of those forested
systems and you know receive some mutual
benefits
and
in addition to that allowing our land to
remain as forested and increasing the
amount of trees in the ground only helps
build our resilience to changing climate
conditions so more and more as we're
experiencing weather shifts farmers are
forced to shift their practices
so they're not continued to be
threatened by these weather events and
that's where agroforestry can really
play a key role in increasing that
resilience on the landscape
okay so i just wanted to give that
background and set that tone um and so
this is where um i work for for most of
the time this is the agroforestry
resource center a part of cce columbia
green
um it was founded in 2003 really to meet
the needs of local residents
who own a lot of forests it's a very
forested county
they're mostly small parcels and you
know people are interested in engaging
with their land
and this just at the time seemed like
the direction to go and today it still
does
and so that center is located in our
green county location in the northern
catskills and is in combination with
siuslaw model forest which was a donated
142 acre teaching forest it was at that
time in 2003 that we merged with
columbia county
which really only furthered
our mission in terms of implementing
agroforestry it was a nice balance that
we found greene county
is more forested and while columbia
county does have beautiful forested
lands they have more agriculture
happening on the landscape so it was a
really nice balance we were able to
to find with this programming
and while we are a local county
organization we engage nationally
regionally
statewide this is a great instance and
and locally
and so i look forward just to
highlighting some of those partnerships
and all the work that's happening
through the country and in the state
that you all could get involved with
so at a national level i think it's
important to note these two
organizations or
um
associations so on the left here we have
the association for temperate
agroforestry also known as afta
and so afta exists nationwide and you
can become a member or just you know
passively engage with their
educational materials
they put out a newsletter
they host a biennial national
agroforestry conference
which hops kind of back and forth from
coast to coast to
try to increase accessibility for folks
to attend
and they also house and sort of oversee
um regional working groups that exist
across the country so i just think it's
important to note that like it's not
just happening here in the northeast
this is countrywide that we're seeing
agroforestry adoption happen and it
takes different forms based on what part
of the country and what the climate is
like there
and then another great partner and
amazing resource is the usda's national
agroforestry center and their work
really focuses on research and
science-based outreach
and through that research they produce
amazing tools that can be very
supportive of land management decisions
and they engage with extensive
partnerships so they're not siloed they
partner with universities nonprofit
organizations state federal agencies and
farmers and practitioners as
well so honing in a little more locally
on a regional level um we partner with
many organizations and i thought this
would be a great opportunity to share a
new project that's kicking off this year
which is called climate smart
agroforestry a multi-regional training
for technical service providers
this is a
collaboration among
many different partners
so it includes interlaced commons out of
the northeast appalachian sustainable
development coming from the southeast
um the savannah institute from the
midwest and with the partner of the
national agroforestry center
and we are all working together to
improve agroforestry technical
assistance around forest farming
alley cropping and silver pasture
what what's become really evident
is that
agroforestry education and adoption has
been happening for the past decade or or
more
and um these practitioners are
starting to seek some some help from
technical service providers um nrcs soil
and water all these other
entities that they're used to engaging
in through their farming endeavors but
a lot of those folks who work for those
entities aren't very well oriented to
agroforestry because it hasn't just
hasn't really been a part of their work
so we've sort of reached a little bit of
a bottleneck where we have a lot of
interest a lot of energy building and we
want to make sure that there's nothing
that will stop that momentum from moving
forward um so through this partnership
we're going to be creating
pretty robust demonstrations in each of
those three different regions of the
country
and we'll also be creating curriculum
for
practitioners for technical service
providers
in a special set of curriculum for nrcs
staff as well
so we're really excited about this
upcoming work and you should be hearing
about some training starting next year
all right so even more locally at a
statewide level
we work with an amazing team it's a
cornell work team called agroforestry in
new york state
the team formed a few years ago
and it is about 25 members from
extension offices across the street
across the state and we maintain a
strong partnership with cornell
university
so we we formed a few years ago with
some goals that included just really
assessing the awareness and adoption of
agroforestry
and furthering um the outreach and
education that we provide
and it also seemed pretty evident that
like we were all doing this work in
different parts of the state so it was a
way for us to not duplicate efforts and
to really build off of each other's
efforts and um
you'll see in the image here just a
quick snapshot off of our website these
are the the different topics or
expertise that are like housed in our
team
and um our website isn't really meant to
house all of these resources it's more
of a directory like if you're interested
in one of these topics you can find
a point person to talk to or resources
to kind of kick off
with your education
and so a little bit more about the work
that that team does um in order to kind
of just further understand or better
understand where everyone's at with
agroforestry you know instead of making
assumptions about what people want to
learn
we are currently launching a statewide
survey
um so this survey is to just do exactly
that get the just an assessment of
awareness and adoption
who who knows and understands what about
agroforestry
and who's practicing what different
systems throughout the state and so i
would encourage um anyone and everyone
who works on land in new york state in
any form to take this survey
and you can find it at our team's
website which is cornell
agroforestry.org
that should be open for maybe another
month or two so i'd encourage you to get
in there and and fill out fill it out
so in addition to that survey the team
also does uh webinars it's a bi-monthly
series that we started last year and it
was really popular so we're going to do
it again this year
and the topics really range from
beginner to advanced so i'd encourage
you just to check those out and you can
go on to the same website the surveys at
to find out about that one and if you're
interested in staying tuned in to what
we're working on you can join our mail
list
and i'll say we've got some members of
the team on the panel today which is
great to see
all right and then so at our
agroforestry resource center i mentioned
in the overview of the center that we
house a 142 acre
demonstration forest called the siusla
model forest
that was graciously donated to us by a
man named eric rasmussen who stewarded
this land as a new york state tree farm
and a practicing forester since
the early 1960s
it's a land that he loved and cared for
and always opened to the public so he as
part of his legacy planning
donated that to us and it's where we're
able to
practice and showcase a lot of these um
agroforestry techniques
so on site there we do a ton of
programming um
you know our office runs the spectrum of
cornell cooperative extension topics but
i'm just going to focus on the
agroforestry related ones today
so in the world of forest farming you
know we work on mushroom identification
mushroom cultivation
ginseng production
general edible and medicinal plant
workshops and these are all offered to
a range of audiences sometimes they're
just general um
open to the public and other times
they're more geared toward
technical service providers and yet
other times they're more geared towards
farmers looking towards enterprise
planning
and in addition to those
agroforestry focused
programming we also just do more general
forestry so my work is really rooted in
forestry and so we focus on forest
health workshops tree regeneration
mainly around deer browse limitations
and we also host a number of logger
trainings
and so in addition to those local
programs that we do
as i mentioned we maintain and build
demonstrations throughout that landscape
so there's a brochure and trails and you
can take kind of like a self-guided
trail to see some of these different
demos
but some of them include
understory herbs woodland mushrooms
maple syrup which we're
getting out of trees in the sap form
right now
and some fruit and nut crop demos
and as i mentioned with that regional
partnership throughout the northeast
southwest and midwest
more robust demonstrations are being
built so cyusa will house a more robust
forest farming demonstration we are
expanding our shiitake laying yard to
represent commercial production and
we're building a larger scale understory
herb
farm in the woods
and then in addition to those programs
and demonstrations we also do a bit of
resource development
we engage in a series called grow manage
harvest where we try to at least once a
year put out
a new guide to an agroforestry crop so
i've highlighted here our pawpaw guide
we also create some ginseng fact sheets
mainly around um
regular regulations that are oriented
towards conservation so just making sure
that you know growers and people
interested in ginseng are really rooted
in those
conservationally minded regulations
and then just a few others around some
other agroforestry practices
we're currently creating a
multifunctional riparian buffer guide
so that's building a buffer of plants
along a waterway that is just filled
with fruit nuts
and any other kind of crops that you can
think of that come from a plant
um a wetland plant guide which is hyper
local to the
the northern catskills where we work so
we can all be really conscious of
ecologically sensitive habitats
and then we also do a bit in the way of
assessment tools again just to help
people match the right crops to the
landscape
and that is it for me
that was sort of a rapid fire overview
of everything i do and i think we do
have a few minutes for questions but
thanks for listening to my talk
thanks so much tracy that was um yes
super interesting i'm so excited for all
the new developments happening can't
wait to hear any future updates
i would love to see if anyone has any
questions for tracy at this time
thanks for sticking the survey link in
there
yes and please share that if you know
other folks throughout the states or um
is that the the usda one
i'm not sure which
there's both the usda there's both like
nationwide and new york state surveying
yeah the usda is doing a nationwide one
building off of the ag census but this
is just the statewide one
well if there are no questions you'll
just have to come come visit we're open
to the public come for a walk
so i'll be talking about hazelnuts uh
generally what it takes to get hazelnuts
in the ground and growing
we're going to talk about
um
all things about hazelnuts and what you
can do with them
so
an overview
whoops my
dancer is not working
there
um
so we're going to talk about his nuts in
general
uh
how they're great for our unused
hillsides to help regenerate the soil
and uh why you want to plant a hazeltree
in the first place what it takes to get
them to grow properly
spacing planting propagation
and the economics of
a hazelnut orchard
and what types of species and or
cultivars are available
and then in the end
something that's near and dear to our
heart
samantha's very much involved with it as
well is a farmer cooperative we
formed of about two and a half years ago
to process all the nuts from hazelnuts
as well as chestnuts and other native
nuts
so i'm gonna have a lot of slides i'm
gonna go relatively fast but i thought
i'd give it spend a little time on the
background so that uh he understands uh
how i'm going to proceed through this
talk
so
hazelnuts are native to the region i did
not know that when i first moved down to
hilltop overlooking cortland new york
and we saw the hillsides being filled in
with
scrub brush and
you know sumac
striped maple trees you know the initial
trees that take over the fields we
thought what a waste so we started
planting
trees of all different kinds trying to
find what trees would grow great in our
region and we quickly found out the
chestnuts and hazelnuts
grew well and we learned they were
native here to begin with
so
you know
we were glad to find out we weren't
fighting what nature already had
intended
so
we spent our time mainly on hazelnuts
and secondarily on chestnuts there was a
lot of people working on chestnuts and
almost nobody working on hazelnuts for
our region
so we planted many thousands of
hazelnuts and we found that uh
there had to be a hybrid between our our
nuts our native nuts cordless americana
with the europeans because the europeans
have done a really good job over
thousands of years developing the
hazelnut to be thin shell larger and
tasty
so
the problem though with european hazel
is that they are not cold hardy and die
from our native blight we call eastern
filbert blight
so
people have been
trying to hybridize the tube for over a
hundred years as documented by the
northern nut growers association
and
uh our native hazels
in comparison to the european hazels are
much smaller our native hazel is like a
bush from a small to a large lilac bush
whereas the european hazels are often 25
35 feet tall once they're very mature
so
if you notice most orchards especially
apple origins they're going towards
smaller and smaller and smaller trees
they can have higher density
ease of harvesting and whatnot so our
native bushes are actually a good form
form to be in
and it turns out when you hybridize the
two they tend to be
are bush size but a little bigger
so
for example though you can see our
native nuts here
are on the top they tend to be much
smaller and tend to have a thicker shell
compared to the nuts down below
the nuts down below are not
european nuts but they are hybrid nuts
hybridized with europeans they often can
have the same size
of nut
and size not meat and thinner shells
this is what we've been working hard on
with at z nutty ridge for
uh well since 1993. so we've been put a
lot of effort into it where we live and
eat and breathe hazelnuts and you'll see
as we go through
all right so i'm going to speed up a bit
here but to add what we were just given
by tracy uh that 60 some percent of the
new york state
is forested it wasn't that way back in
1890. uh we went to the local library
and went through the
uh census
and at one point in the census at i
think it was yeah 1890 96 of all the
land in cortland county was cleared
and you can see from uh in the picture
above
the hillsides as far as you can see were
cleared except for some tree line and a
few dotted trees here and there this is
a drawing which is supposed to be a
rendering of of what actually was seen
in courtland county back in the 1890.
same picture down below slightly
different angle but you can see where
the hillsides are filled back in they
grew poor eroded and farmers stop
uh you know
farming
so why is this well i call them nature's
power plant they uh
with uh this cultivars i'm we'll be
showing you they can produce two times
the oil of soybeans per acre
and economics are
quite nice
also
hazelnuts are a known commodity to all
the people
and people love recently in the last 10
years there's been a groundswell of
people wanting to source their food
locally
and that's extremely healthy
report after report after report
constantly coming out
that nuts are extremely healthy and
should be part of the
daily diet
and there's all kinds of good
information i won't read the stats but
bottom line is one of the papers i read
said that
people who consume nuts three times or
more a week
die 20 less from all
um
mortality causes
across the board and that's reason
enough to be eating more nuts
okay so our they're native already so
you know that our soil is already
adopted for them and i can go into
details here but basically they're like
more neutral type soils they can handle
uh you know five four five eight won't
grow as well as they could but they like
towards
uh neutral
we have plenty of water natively in the
area you know at least 30 inches of rain
a year they are very happy last year we
had a lot of rain year before last we
had a very dry year they came through
some trees are hurt a little but
otherwise they came through without any
irrigation
and i already discussed the hybrids and
the native trees uh can and need to be
hardy
so fertilizing you the native trees
really don't need much fertilizing
they can be amended with you know mulch
and manures
you can
let them grow as a bush or as a single
stem tree
there are
maintenance guides along with the book
that my wife and i have written
teaching you and showing you how to
maintain the orchard it's actually
fairly low impact
compared to growing peppers or
other annual vegetables
so
hazel's are wind pollinated so you don't
have to worry about bees these help no
doubt
but hazel's do not need wind and to that
extent need to make sure you have good
pollinating
uh male flowers in the in your orchard
and so nowadays we recommend that you
have one row out of five or six rows no
more than one out of four rows the
seedlings then the other whole rows be
cultivars
and the neat thing is these flowers you
can see they're teeny tiny flowers size
of a bud itself you don't even notice
them if you're more than like 10 feet
away
they're receptive four to six weeks
they'll sit there and wait and wait and
wait for pollen to come along so your
main job is to make sure you have good
pollen
available
so when you plant hazel's they're often
they're small trees as we already
discussed they're generally less than
three feet often six to eighteen inches
tall
especially seedlings the first year old
ones
the cultivars can be two or three feet
tall they're you can dig them by hand
but large numbers you often want to use
like a tree transplanter
and we also suggest that because
the
bushes are so tasty to deer and rodents
when they're young before they develop a
thick bark
we strongly recommend you put hardware
cloth around the trees as well as
a fence the deter the deer from trying
to get in
and oh there's our transplanter that we
use on our farm
so
our spacing goes you can go as close as
eight feet apart within a row if you're
planting an orchard and we suggest you
have at least 16 feet between rows not
more than 18 feet
if you just want to plant a hedgerow you
can plant as close as three feet for a
quick privacy but generally not more
than seven feet if you want you know a
true hedgerow
like i said earlier you can grow these
in tree form you can just let them grow
as a single stem or a few stems natively
they want to grow as a 20 30 40 stem
bush
we don't fully recommend that
this the base of the bush gets very wide
and a lot of nuts can drop down at the
base so it kind of hinders harvesting
but you can harvest them with a vacuum
harvester if they're a bush or a tree
we don't go much in the harvest in this
talk but it's basically establishment of
orchards
so like anything else when you first
plant it to get the roots going you
suggest your water like i said already
got to protect from rodents
of all kinds the other pests are
japanese beetles
they uh you can you can spray but
basically beetle traps work best
uh just stop before they ever get
started
um
you have to be careful when you mulch
trees you want to acidify the soil next
to the tree so you have to make sure you
you lime the trees from time to time the
other
problem that we're starting to see now
is big bud mite it's really just getting
started in our
orchards there are sprays lime sulfur as
well as commercial sprays you can use
to control big bud might
some trees are naturally resistant to
big bug bite
so as long as you know how to avoid
these issues i think hazel's are
the next up and coming crop with a very
bright future
so here's an orchard planted in 2017 we
show the hardware cloth cages
um
hang on a second we show the hardware
cloth cages
and irrigation line that we have taken
out we only have the hard cloth cages on
for a couple years until the trees form
a bark and they're not tasty to roads
and the irrigation lines we pick up and
move
there is an orchard that's one year
younger it was planted in 2018 and you
can see the plastic at the base of the
trees we're layering the trees we're
encouraging the suckers to form their
own roots so we can split them off and
form clones it's one of our main jobs
here at z nutty
so
you know i talked about just getting the
hazelnuts established
the main thing that the whole purpose of
getting trees establishes your core for
uh agroforestry is to add all the other
options that you have available to you
one uh potential quad member joining our
new york tree crops alliance wants to
herd ducks in his pasture he says ducks
are great grass eaters he's been growing
for a long time and now he wants to span
his duck operation through a hazelnut
orchard i'm tickled with that
and i did not see that described well in
other agroforestry practices
so economics
if you just plant seedlings you're going
to get between 120 pounds to 1300 pounds
per acre
uh umhd i found out that's upper midwest
hazelnut development initiative
so you really can't plant just seedlings
and expect to break even even for your
efforts
uh and that's when you plant five or six
hundred bushes to acre
uh they say
over plant
and uh eliminate two to three times or
two or three trees per tree that you
keep they're great for pollination
insurances already discussed but the
bottom line is if you plant mainly
cultivars as i discussed you can get two
to four thousand pounds per acre
direct web sales that's at six dollars a
pound in shell that's 12 to 16 000 an
acre b2b sales like
uh straight to course grocery stores and
outlets you're around three 350 maybe a
little more a pound now that's seven
thousand to fourteen thousand an acre
commodity sales like you're selling to
ferraro just over the border so they can
make nutella and uh
chocolate-covered hazelnuts you're only
getting going to get 24 to 4 800 baker
but that's way higher than any annual
grain crop that you can grow
and
and here's a picture i love it shows a
plant that we just patented called
photon
very round nuts very short husks very
large
uh nuts at that
and it produces like crazy uh we
harvested 22 pounds off this tree this
last fall
and an orchard full of that would be
well over four thousand pounds per acre
in a good and this was a good year last
year so you can't take that you're not
going to get that every year but some
years you're going to get you know those
kind of yields
so we talked about
harvard hazel cultivars five years ago
there weren't any now we have 37. and
what makes a good cultivar so that keeps
using the word and cultivars just keep
in mind are just clones of a really good
uh parent mom tree
so
you have to have efb resistance i told
you that already because they're
hybridizing with european trees you need
to make sure they maintain the local
disease resistance
you need to make sure you're compatible
with your zone make sure the tree is
rated for your zone that you're in of
course nut quality but there's a whole
bunch of secondary other issues you have
to worry about
here's a chart i already discussed half
of it but bottom line is you want the
nuts to taste well some nuts gonna taste
downright earthy you don't want that you
want that nice hazelnut coffee flavor
you expect or that um
nutella flavor
another thing that people like they like
well actually commercial growers want
this they want nuts to blanch well
we found out that the pellicle around
the nut is very healthy for you and
maybe shouldn't be removed but for
confections they like to
blanch to take the pelican off the nut
we already talked about big mic mud mite
resistance roundness is an ideally
ideally convection thing not for out of
hand eating something we'll talk about
pollen compatibility uh not all trees
cultivars will cult will pollinate each
other but seedlings if you have a rose
seedlings you have to worry about it and
pollen timing it's
somewhat of an issue but not really
flowers will sit there and wait for four
to six weeks
and then genetic diversity we want to
maintain genetic diversity you that's
another reason to have a row of
pollinators we want to find more
cultivars in a row of pollinators we'll
which are seedlings will do that for us
so there are 33 identified
different pollen types
identified by their alleles s alleles at
that
and two trees cannot have the same first
s allele otherwise they won't cross
pollinate each other so if you plant a
row of
of cultivars all the same clone
you should plant a different clone in
the next row
and check their alleles if available to
make sure they can cross-pollinate each
other but then again if you have a row
of seedlings this is not an issue but we
just want to make you aware of the issue
that you could have if you blindly plant
all the same tree
which people are sometimes get so
energetic they just want to get trees
planted and they don't double check
themselves
so we actually have cultivars down to
zone three uh being developed by umhdi
and at gremo nursery which is just over
the border past buffalo into canada they
themselves are in zone seven but they
work with a modern experimental farm in
manitoba canada
so they've
found some very hardy native trees
that are productive and some are
hybridized to uh and they were lucky to
maintain that hardiness while getting
larger nuts
so in 405 we have another grouping of
trees that are good
also from grimo ourselves at z nutty
ridge
and
a couple other nurses are reselling
what's been developed by
the hazelnut consortium which is a
network of
colleges university of nebraska oregon
state university and rutgers university
and our day foundation so these uh it's
called the consortium trees they're
being released and grown by some
nurseries including ourselves
god darn it
and then zones six and seven these again
are grimos
foggy bottom reselling uh ruckers and
ourselves are selling uh one of rucker's
releases called hunterdon along with
foggy bottom
so
um at our nursery i'll highlight what we
have and i'll show you the other nurses
and where they're located next we saw uh
one called fire called grand traverse
um and i have over on the right column
when they're available this spring or f
or if we have to wait till next fall
because we're growing them out
the beast was a consortium released a
very aggressive growing tree it's going
to be a taller tree produces like crazy
very nice nuts 100
is the rutgers release very nice
european it's actually uh european
that's been bred to have efb resistance
nica is our own
uh release red sea's nutty uh
phonetically named after our new york
new york tree crops alliance trucks
another release that we uh
sell that we have here photon is the one
i just told you we just filed a patent
on beautiful tree in geneva which was
formed by cornell professors back in the
40s and 50s
it's an okay tree not quite cold hardy
enough um but it's an okay tree
and then we sell seedlings
out of the 10 000 trees that we grown to
maturity over many years now
uh we have eight trees that we sell
seeds from only eight good trees at a
ten thousand so that's a hint on uh
seedlings
um
so
from seven trees we sell the nuts from
cortland is seeds only from nica nika
has very thin shells and it passes that
um
those characteristics onto its many of
its seedlings so we made that separately
then prodigies are controlled crosses
that we use from our best trees
and we give the growers a chance to find
the next generation cultivar
so in blue are regional nurseries that
you can get
seedlings as well some cultivars from
foggy bottom ontario which is grimo nut
twisted tree which is in spencer new
york st lawrence nursery uh like it
sounds and ourselves located here in
cortland new york
so we got all these people growing
nutrients and we needed a cooperative to
process this nuts and sell the nuts and
process them sanitarily with quality in
mind and hopefully brand building so
people can recognize the efforts of the
growers
so we uh believe that a co-op will
be environmentally sustainable use of
all the fallow lands which we discuss in
our motivations for growing trees in the
first place
and the norches itself will expand
farming
uh enable people to start farming that
haven't been able to farm as our native
hillside lands are dirt cheap compared
to uh many farmlands throughout the
nation and as an example
uh acreage for hazelnuts and oregon are
going for twenty thousand dollars an
acre
so we can get hillside land around here
for fifteen hundred bucks an acre if you
buy it a little bit
uh and the unfortunate aspect of that is
eventually it'll do such a good job
economically i bet you'll increase taxes
tax
revenue
it'll allow exports and of course we
hope agritourism
a couple more slides and we're done i
got to be running out of time
so the co-op will
oversee the marketing the sales the
branding the sanitary processes and
procedures you need kitchen and storage
certificate certification for your nuts
clean shell and roast the nuts as well
as
um
went a little too fast
as well as do all the value-added
processing we're working with topkin ccc
oh for agroforestry that got cut off we
have a grant thanks to samantha for
highlighting this potential grant to us
we will be
um
introducing people to
agroforestry uh monitoring and
agroforestry practices as well as
develop value-added products and
purchase the equipment needed for those
value-added products
so you can see where the big circle here
is where we plan to be
immediately as far as servicing farmers
ultimately we'd love to see the
cooperative be able to service all
throughout the region
and here's some references should you
need them to go look up data on umhdi
ourselves uh different presentations
have been done in the past cooperative
extension bulletins the work of
of uh tom molnar dr molnar at
university of
rutgers and
a book we like growing nuts in the north
so i'm glad you were able to give this
presentation and we appreciate the uh
attendance
thank you so much jeff there's been
quite some discussion happening in the
chat i'm wondering if you have a couple
minutes to answer a couple questions
yeah in particular people are very
curious about the truffles
um and if you know of anyone who's
actually currently doing that if these
are wes if you know anything about the
species of troubles that people are
using
um
yeah that's one that's one set of
questions i could speak a little bit to
that um there is a finger lakes truffle
farm
and i think you can search on the
internet quick enough to find it uh they
started us like seven eight years ago
um
i'm not sure what trees they're actually
growing but they're starting to harvest
truffles if you go to the facebook page
you'll see the lady holding a handful of
truffles which is wonderful
it's something we always wanted to do
last year we contacted a
a company in north carolina who will
gladly
uh inoculate the trees you have to
inoculate the roots of the trees before
you plant them i don't know what truffle
she's growing but for some reason
burgundy's uh popping up in my head
so i'm not sure but yes people are are
growing truffles in new york state
amazing thank you
another person is asking about has a
particular question about hazelnuts they
said they are in zone four they have
three hazelnut bushes
that are 10 years old and no nuts what
do you suggest
uh you need
colder heartier trees a lot of times
trees will go just fine but the flowers
in the cat the male and female flowers
won't survive the winter so the tree
grows fine but no fruit
so
you need to procure some colder
you know heartier trees either st
lawrence myself
uh at our nursery or even a kiva twisted
tree they can provide trees for you
is it possible too that three
hazelnut bushes alone may not be enough
to actually get
proficient wind pollination
uh no not at all hazelnut pushes should
be fine for uh providing pollination
okay
greens
well
um some students can even ask questions
and then i encourage you to stay tuned
to the very end where we can have more
uh more of a discussion with our
presenters
um
okay anna is now also asking if you can
help if pruning trees would help
increase nut production do you know much
about pruning
jackson so i i
presented at rutgers university a few
years back and there was the
representative for ferraro
ferraro by 65 of the world's
commercially sold nuts
so they're they're the gorilla of the
marketplace
and he said the science is settled jeff
not trees produce more nuts than than
not bushes
in this case he was talking hazelnut
bushes
um
and i was a little surprised to hear
that
uh in turkey they grow them as
semi-bushes they grow them like four or
five stems um so it's a tight base
and i think ultimately that's where
we're gonna end up because if you let
the bushes grow for 20 years the base of
the bush is three and four feet wide and
it
over the row harvester will just knock a
lot of the seeds down into the
entangled you know bush so i think
turkey's figured it out they have small
orchards you know four to 15 acres
and they got it i i think that's what
we'll end up
howdy everyone so samantha just said i
work as a regional extension forester
and yet the other full-time job outside
of extension is our family has a large
grass-fed beef operation we graze about
500 acres here on the west side of
watkins glen and
at least a few hundred acres more from
neighbors for hay production
so i like to talk about
forestry stuff i like to talk about cows
and why i can talk about them both
together
that's
that's like the best of both worlds for
me so i think this topic of civil
pasturing
fits in nicely to everything else we're
talking about this afternoon because i
think a civil pasture is kind of the
canvas and then we can build all these
other agroforestry systems
into it
so
the conversation
around civil pasturing really started
a little over 20 years ago
cornell
several colleagues of mine tatiana stan
who's our small ruminant specialist
peter smallidge he's our state extension
forester
and some other folks did this northeast
air funded project
at cornell's are not teaching research
forest which is i'm
today i'm the forest manager at the
arnott that's a it's a part-time duty
and they were looking at the
effectiveness and the cost-effectiveness
of using
livestock particularly goats to control
problematic
forest
understory vegetation and
the
summary of the project was yes
managed correctly livestock could be
a useful tool to do that it was quite
labor intensive
and i think that's where it would be a
challenge for many livestock farmers
that are just
they may very well work full time on the
farm but they still have other things
like full-time jobs
to keep them busy so
this project
came to an end and when i joined
extension 2007
there were a lot of lingering questions
about from
everybody like hey you know i remember
the goats in the woods can i do that
with my cattle can i do with my sheep
and of course foresters
were asking about this and so we decided
to formally start talking about
civil pasturing in fact our very first
talk was over
where tracy works there at the
green columbia agroforestry center i
remember it was the most perfect
day in june of saturday
that we picked for this talk in other
words the absolute worst time
imaginable to try and get a
audience full of farmers and yet we had
a basically standing room only crowd
that wanted to come here about civil
pasturing and it just kind of
mushroomed from there so
why do we get excited about civil
pasturing today well
if you look and this is a
aerial image from just north of our farm
here in watkins glen you can see that
our farmland is really this kind of
mix of woods and mix of fields or
pastures and
uh statistically new york is about
two-thirds covered with forests and yet
throughout most most of our agricultural
regions it's about 50 50 mix and
these are
statistics that are a compilation of
various
uh
reports and
sort of expert consensuses but
i'm not going to cite them but we
estimate that we have about 3 million
acres of
this former agricultural land which is
usually either today in an invasive
shrub complex
or farm woodlots that have been
either mismanaged over time what we call
high graded or
there was storm damage or
some some significant loss to some some
pests like emerald ash borer
and then we also have
what's called underutilized grasslands
and pastures
uh so it's not like if we're looking to
make a difference in terms of rural
economic development and
adding to our self-sufficiency as a
state or a region to grow more food in
our backyard this is something that has
the potential
to do it at a scale of you know not just
a few thousand acres i mean literally
millions of acres and
it's important to recognize too though
that this opportunity for civil
pasturing
can be approached from either of these
two directions we can be enhancing our
pastures in our existing
grazing lands by introducing trees
and all of you
joining in today
i'm sure are experienced tree planters
and recognize that there's a little more
to this than just
digging a hole and putting the tree in
the ground walking away from it
in fact i consider it the more
challenging side of
establishing civil pastures but then we
have again this very significant acreage
of
just
either farm woodlots that are
kind of not
as much as they could be because of
pests or past
management and these farm plantations
so regardless of which of these two
directions we're starting from the goal
is this image that you see in the middle
which is
getting
quality forages and quality functional
trees and then this this herbivore
component which makes it unique from
these other agroforestry systems all
working together in a synergistic
fashion and
back when i was in forestry school 30
some years ago
it was
ingrained into our
young forestry minds that thou shall not
put livestock in the woods and i can
talk about where that kind of european
forestry model came from and
really it was it was good advice though
when we started uh
trying to shift farmers thinking away
from using their woods
is the kind of sacrifice paddock on the
farm
and you can still see plenty of this on
the landscape and
you know
wooded areas that are being treated
again where you put the animals when
it's too hot or too cold or too muddy or
the good grounds planted when you have
this unmanaged
or
i should say sort of like continual
unmanaged grazing in these areas you see
these symptoms illustrated here of
denuded uh
soil erosion exposed roots decline in
the health and vigor of the trees
trees that are blowing over because of
compromised root systems so
but silvopasturing is some a completely
different beast and first and foremost
it is intensive rotational grazing this
is an aerial image of our farm just the
home farm portion outlined in purple
and it's about 200 acre farm and what i
want you to see here though is that this
is a fairly dated map but even back
probably a dozen years ago when i did
this map
we already had our farm chopped into 50
different paddocks
that averaged a few acres in size and
across the 500 acres that we're
currently grazing
that's divided into almost 130 paddocks
so
our herd is constantly on the move i'm
not going to get into the
details today of just
you know how we do our rotational
grazing i will say that
it's adaptive
management so sometimes we're moving
multiple times a day sometimes we may
only move every two or three days
but
what this allows us to do is
a really increased density so we can put
a lot of animals in a small panic for a
short period of time
they eat the best
third half of what's there but they
pound and trample
the rest of it which kind of again
levels the playing field so you're not
just having them selectively graze the
good stuff and they ignore the woody
invasive plants or the weeds they
trample and smash and
knock down a lot of those plants and in
the process fertilize it well
it's not
most livestock is not going to defoliate
the undesirable plants the point where
it's really going to make any difference
at all
we
[Music]
do this year round so we're grazing
about eight months of the year and then
we are feeding round bales for the other
four months of the year and we as soon
as the ground freezes up which this year
wasn't really until the first of january
we try to shift gears and feed as much
of that hay as possible
in our civil pasture paddocks
not feeding bales in the same spot over
and over so that it smothers tree roots
and
harms the trees what we're trying to do
is put these friend of mine
jewelry fije who's another
forcer like civil pasturing
calls them bail bombs and you put these
round bales in these patches of soft
brush so on top of the multiflora rose
canes or the honeysuckle or the barberry
these things that normally you just
won't be able to control with grazing
and defoliation
and when if you do the math when you put
20 hungry cows around one of these bales
in that 30 foot diameter circle it's a
million and a half pounds of density per
acre which is far more than we can
achieve during the grazing season
and it not only really puts a beat down
on this bad brush but it also fertilizes
it leaves a lot of viable seed there so
you get this little oasis of
lush herbaceous growth the following
year which in turn helps suppress the
growth of the
woody invasives and it's now once and
done deal so you may have to do this
multiple times over
maybe
the course of a decade or more but each
time you do it it's setting it back just
that much more
so why do we do silver pasturing well
for one thing it allows us to use our
whole farm not just the half that
doesn't have trees on it but we really
think of it as a way of rehabilitating
our woods much of our
woodland understory on the farm was
dense invasive
shrubs or native species like beech
brush
and
advance i won't go into all the forestry
reasons today why we don't like that but
it's just we wanted a healthier more
productive more attractive woods and we
felt that we could still have
all the benefits of the woods but use it
to support our grazing operation as well
and we could take any one of these
bullet points here and talk about for
the rest of the afternoon
um here's one that wasn't on that list
and kind of an obvious one it's like we
can be growing multiple things on the
same site and there's a pile some of our
locust posts and one of our locust
walnut
plantation civil pastures and we have
literally
harvested tens of thousands of dollars
of
locust fence posts over the years from
locust trees that we planted here 30
years ago
if you're into carbon and we all should
be as farmers today then you know this
is this is like the top
land-based system for
capturing and storing more carbon and
i've done some
calculations for our own farm and our
civil pastures whether it's a plantation
silver pasture or a woodlot silver
pasture
i estimate that we're growing some or
growing and i should probably i don't
know about the storing part but
somewhere between 50 and 100 percent
more carbon per acre
and civil pasture versus just woods or
just open pasture
and you may have noticed their uh
resilience you know i think that's
really
resilience and regenerative for the
should be to our two main focuses today
this is a
photo of a 2011 drought on our farm and
these pictures were taken a week a week
apart so you can kind of see the dusty
dry brown
burnt up conditions there around that
was taken around the fourth of july and
then a week later the
cows are up to their backs and lush
green stuff and
we also use an adaptation of this we we
call living barns so these are more
coniferous type
plantations on the farm we're still
thinning them out trying to
really promote tree growth and vigor but
we're not as
keen on trying to thin it out to the
point where we're growing a lot of
forage underneath we have six of these
areas
scattered around the 500 acres and we
just watched the 10-day forecast and
when the big storms come in
like it did here a few weeks ago
we've got these areas well stocked with
bales
for a few days
these are areas that are on well-drained
soils they got water nearby
and the cows are snug as a bug in a rug
riding out the
worst of the winter weather in these
areas so if you'd like to learn more
about this we've been
slowly compiling a number of different
resources over the years
these are some things you can find on
the
cornell cooperative extension forestry
extensions site the forest connect dot
info we've got things like these uh sort
of
site
site um evaluation tools they're
you know you know
it to me it would be a logical starting
point if you're thinking about doing
civil passion we have
a civil pasture management plan template
which you could share maybe with your
forester
to help you do some more formal planning
we have this silvopasture forum here
it currently has about 600 members and
we understand you're not going to go on
every evening and post stuff and read
all the good stuff that's archived there
but if you join this and
when we do a big event
related to civil pasturing we will
message the members so i'm talking like
two or three times a year but you won't
miss out on something
important like this here and i'll i'll
close out using this opportunity to
invite you all to
our civil pasture tour
which will be september 15th and 16th
and we will be putting more details up
soon on the forum so that's all
fantastic thank you so much brent
in addition to my work with extension
and the education and outreach that i do
around forest farming and mushroom
production i also
own a small
forest farm
growing mainly shiitakes
managing about 300 bolts or so
so
this is a favorite topic of mine so i'm
happy to step in
and i'm excited to talk to you about
mainly shiitakes let's talk a little bit
about some other mushrooms but you'll
see as i go on in my talk why the focus
is on shiitakes
so i'm just going to give a quick
overview of like fungus as an organism i
know many of us work with plants and
animals and there's been a lot more
interest in mycology but just to make
sure we're all on the same page
i'll introduce shiitakes
share some growing considerations that
you might want to think through if you
are contemplating
cultivating this mushroom
and then we'll get into some more
specifics on exactly how the cultivation
works and how you manage your bolts and
we'll talk a little bit at the end about
scaling up and what enterprise building
around this crop looks like
okay so sometimes i use the word like
fungus and mushroom interchangeably but
just to clarify
mushrooms are the fruiting body of the
fungus
so like an apple on an apple tree they
come out seasonally at certain parts of
the year and mushrooms engage in asexual
reproduction using spores
so a regular mushroom has a cap on the
underside it has gills where it produces
spores
it has a stem that's called a stalk or a
stipe
and then you see the underground section
of the mushroom is coming from
the fungal organism
the mycelium and individual threads of
that mycelium are hyphae
and mushrooms are of course decomposers
in our natural world
and so this is just a nice close-up of
mycelium in action where you can see
those individual threads
of hyphae
i believe this is wine cap stropharia
cultivating um wood chips in a jar
before they were planted out into a
field
so just a little bit of history about
shiitake on
similarly to all the other agroforestry
practices that we've talked about this
is nothing new
shiitakes have been cultivated for
thousands of years um they're native to
japan china and korea
and the word
she means tree and take means mushroom
so it's literally a tree mushroom
and shiitakes are
weak pathogens
meaning that they're they're not too
competitive out in the natural world so
they struggle on their own to gain
a foothold in a decomposing log
and so they're not native to our
ecosystem
and without intentional cultivation you
won't find them growing in the woods
because of that weak pathogen
piece
and they are sacrificed so they they
live and grow on dead cut wood
and so mushroom identification is pretty
important like i said when you're
intentionally growing shiitakes um
they will grow much better and colonize
that log really well um but just a quick
overview um the cap is like a light to
dark brown and it often has white specks
on it the gills the underside are really
light like white to a very light brown
and the stem is the same color and maybe
the most important feature is the spore
color
so the image here you see is a score
print
and that's just the cap of a mushroom
with the stem cut off
placed on black paper with a bowl or
something over that mushroom cap to
reduce
wind flow
and those spores just fall out onto the
black paper and leave this for print and
so we can clearly see
white colored spores which is a great
identifier
and maybe just as important as knowing
the mushrooms that you eat is knowing
their
poisonous lookalikes so this is
gallerina also known as deadly gallerina
and it's perhaps maybe the only um
wild mushroom in our ecosystem that
could be confused with shiitakes they do
also grow on
dead wood
and have like a brownish color to them
the main difference is the spore color
they have a rusty sort of brown spore
so if you're ever in doubt just let it
sit on a piece of paper and double check
the score color
they're very different though once you
get to know the mushrooms it's easy to
to see many other features that
distinguish the two
and so mushrooms have really similar
needs to plants and even to us humans um
so they obviously need food um
there are brown raw mushrooms versus
white rot whether they consume cellulose
or lignin the components of
that downed wood
they need water
they need to breathe air mushrooms
actually take in oxygen and omit co2
just like us
they do need light many people think
that mushrooms just grow in the dark and
while they do need to be protected from
direct sunlight in some cases they do
require a light cycle to produce
um so in addition to protection from
direct sun they also need protection
from wind pests and predators just like
any other crop
and so in essence in a very simplistic
way this is the process for shiitake
cultivation
you fell a tree
you
you inoculate that freshly filled tree
it has to incubate for a period about 12
months and then it starts going through
this cycle of
forcing it to fruit
harvesting potentially processing and
selling
allowing a shorter incubation period to
happen and then continuing on in that
loop for four or five years maybe more
with the same piece of wood
so we're going to dive into that a
little bit more detail
all right so if you're thinking about
growing mushrooms the first thing you'll
have to do is figure out where you can
source your your wood and again since we
live in the northeast and have so much
forested land it's not terribly
difficult but it can be a bit of a
stumbling block especially for people
who
maybe don't own woods or aren't
comfortable using
a chainsaw which is just fine so there's
some other options for sourcing and
there's still a lot of current work
happening to improve the sourcing
process so there is potential to buy
logs from another landowner or even from
land managers such as loggers
and so shiitakes like to grow on
full-size hardwood species um primarily
oak sugar maple um sometimes red maple
beech uh hornbeam and it can be grown in
other species like birch
and so
um this is where i think shiitakes tie
in with the bigger picture of
agroforestry because for me the most
appealing component of growing this crop
is the opportunity to
manage your woodlands and improve the
health of your woods
so oftentimes
for shiitake growers they'll engage in
timber stand improvement projects so
that's looking at the the landscape as a
whole
and choosing trees that could be thinned
out to improve what's left there
and you can often find great
opportunities to use that pole size wood
that's harvested through the timber
stand improvements to then grow your
crop on
and for harvesting the trees you can you
can really harvest them at any time of
year but there was some research done at
cornell that showed that winter and
like like spring after the sap flow is
done are really the ideal times you'll
receive
the highest level of
of production of shiitake mushrooms from
bolts that are harvested during those
windows but as you can see from the
chart it's it's potentially a lower
output from logs harvested in the summer
and fall but they're still quite
productive i think this really is more
of a key
piece to look at when you're considering
more of a commercial level production
and so when thinking about sourcing if
you are engaged with other
um people sourcing the the wood on your
behalf and purchasing the bolts from
them there's a pretty steep learning
curve um when compared to something else
like cutting logs for timber or firewood
um the most important part of the the
bolt or the piece of wood that you're
growing shiitakes on is that the bark is
intact so it can't be skidded out and
dragged on the ground like much of the
other wood
um that we source from our landscape
um so a lot of communication and
relationship building kind of needs to
happen up front
with those relationships
and so once the tree is is cut and it's
bucked up into sections it turns into a
bolt so a bolt is just a piece of wood
that you've decided to grow mushrooms on
they have some sort of standardized
dimensions that are really developed
around
growing growing considerations so just
ease of handling to pick up and move
these pieces of wood and soak them and
manage them so they're typically four to
six inches in diameter they can be a
little larger but shouldn't be too much
smaller
and they're generally about three to
four feet in length and so this creates
a manageable log with enough food for
the fungus to consume
so after you've sourced your wood
um you need to work on identifying um
spawn and wax to inoculate the wood
and so there's a few different spawn
suppliers there's actually more and more
popping up but here are just a couple
that i wanted to highlight that are
fairly popular and
and pretty um
reliable companies
so you can make spawn at home
sawdust or plug spawn is what's used to
inoculate um shiitake bolts so it'll be
sterilized sawdust that's colonized with
the mycelium or like wooden dowels that
are used in construction that are also
colonized with the mycelium and
generally at a production level we're
looking at using sawdust spawn it's much
more economical
so you can make that at home by
creating some sterilized conditions and
introducing the mycelium and letting it
colonize the sawdust but i i have to say
um purchasing from some of these
reputable suppliers you'll find much
more vigorous
spawn that will produce a lot better
than what i can make at home anyway
and so when you're choosing your spawn
there's a few different options for
strains of shiitakes
and this is where i think it's really
interesting when considering um
climate shifts so typically a wide range
spawn
strain is used and wide range shiitakes
will
fruit from about may to september
when temperatures are averaging you know
at least 70 degrees up to the high 80s
um so they're like the pretty standard
strain that's used in production but
there are two other options that can
really help
extend and create a more consistent
growing season
so cold weather strains
can be used to extend the growing season
and
produce more shiitakes on the shoulder
seasons so as winter is shifting into
spring and as fall is shifting into
winter these
logs will fruit actually on their own
without any forcing
so you'll get a nice extension there
beyond the typical
wide range season
and then warm weather strains are
actually gaining popularity and they're
turning out to perform pretty well in in
the height of summer when we're seeing
consistent high temperatures like above
90.
at that level the wide range spawn will
will sort of shut down
and so um the warm weather can
pick right up and and kind of fill that
gap that you might have in your
production
and then the other piece of material
that you have to source is a wax
and that can be purchased from spawn
suppliers and it's a food grade
wax like not not the wax you use to make
candles but like a cheese wax
all right and so we can dive into the
process of inoculation and this this
graphic just shows that um inoculation
processes really have like three main
stations it's drilling
inoculating with the spawn and waxing
over the holes
oops
a little too fast there
all right so for the inoculation piece
you
drill the holes and you'll see here in
this image of the top corner that we're
using an angle grinder drill
instead of a standard conventional drill
the angle grinder has a lot more power
and
higher rotations so you'll find very
quickly if you're you know using the two
side by side that the angle grinder is
the tool you want to use
you're able to drill those holes so fast
without a lot of effort
and you can actually buy custom drill
bits
that are the right
diameter and depth that will match your
inoculation tool
and that is what you see on the bottom
corner here
that piece of wood and metal sitting on
the bowl is the inoculation tool it's
sort of like a plunger and you stab it
into your spawn and it fills up and then
you align it over the hole you drilled
in your log and fill that hole with the
spawn
and then finally you wax over that hole
with your food grade wax to seal in
moisture and protect the spawn from
rodents or birds that might like to eat
it
so after you have your inoculated bolts
um you need a place to put them and this
place is called a lane yard
um so at this time you would set up your
laying yard and start thinking about
management so you need to just have a
few features of that yard
a water source so you're able to
maintain hydration for those bolts
year-round shade
and that could exist from a natural
canopy cover of evergreens or it may
need to be supplemented like you see in
the photo here
with some ag shade cloth like an 80
shade cloth is great
and then that that area where you're
keeping your logs needs to be
relatively protected from the wind
again it's a moisture management piece
your logs can't dry out so if it's in a
high wind situation you might be
spending more time to manage that
moisture or you might be losing some
logs from your production if they get
too dry
and then the other piece is pests and
predators
that we'll talk about a little bit later
but is not too substantial
so there's a couple different ways to
organize your laying yard and you'll
find through this talk that like any
other farming endeavor shiitake
cultivation offers a lot of room for
innovation and problem solving
and so with that there's a bunch of
different ways you can set up your yard
on the left here you see a crib stack
system and that's where the logs are
just crisscrossed with air space between
them so the fungus can breathe
and this is an area that is protected
from the wind so we can stack vertical
and not worry too much about
wind pressures
and the image on the right there you see
is a hillside method where it's they're
stacked very low so that's more suitable
to a higher wind scenario
and then as you're laying your logs and
letting them rest they need about
12 months for an incubation period and
so while you're waiting through that
incubation period you can work on your
fruiting plans for the next season
this is my
backyard shiitake log production and as
i was setting it up i kept wide paths
between each stack of
of bolts so i can drive a tractor mower
with a trailer through the rows
and you'll see in the back of that
picture
um a livestock tank it's like 150 gallon
tank that i'm able to put on the trailer
of the tractor
and so i can drive the tanks to my
shiitake bolts
when i'm
managing them for water or for forcing
them to fruit
and then i can drive the tractor to the
fruiting racks where i can lean up the
log so i'm not having to carry really
heavy logs all around all the time
and so here's a couple different
examples of what a fruiting rack can
look like and it can be super simple
like the top left corner where you see
bolts just leaning against a pine tree
that bottom left corner they're leaning
against welded wire fence
in the center there's like a fruiting
rack that was built with a piece of wood
a branch that's just attached to the
trees on either side
and then on the far right there's just
simply rope that's been
secured to trees so the logs can lean on
those
so after your logs are inoculated and
set up in their laying yard you need to
wait through that incubation period or
what's also called the spawn run um the
shiitakes need to fully colonize that
piece of wood before they'll start
fruiting you can actually see in the
picture on the left looking at that cut
end of the bolt all that white that's
actually the mycelium actively
colonizing the log
so then after about 12 months have
passed from your inoculation date those
logs are ready to be
forced to fruit and this is what in my
opinion makes shiitakes like the most
optimal crop is you can force them to
fruit and harvest exactly when you want
them or need them
so you soak them in cold clean water for
12 to 24 hours not much longer than that
the logs will reach 100
moisture and the fungus will not be able
to breathe and it will drown and die
and so
here's just a quick example of what a
fruiting schedule might look like um
so
this is
considering perhaps you have seven
different stacks looking at this graphic
and you can see in may and june numbers
one through seven those numbers
represent a stack of logs so you know
there could be anywhere from 10 to 20 or
maybe even 30 logs per stack so the
first week of may
when temperatures start averaging around
70 degrees you're ready to start forcing
your logs to the fruit so you could soak
your first stack the first week of may
and then after they fruit about a week
later they're laid back down to rest
again
and then seven weeks later which would
bring you to the second week of june
those very same logs are ready to be
fruited again
you can actually fruit them up to three
times in one season if you start off
right at the beginning of may
and so those individual logs can be
fruited three times a year and can be
fruited for four or five seasons
and when thinking about harvesting time
there is really an optimal window for
picking your shiitake mushrooms so the
images you see on the left side
show
on the underside of the mushroom the cap
still has the lip on it
and that's when you want to harvest
that's when you'll have optimal
shelf time
and optimal taste
the image that is second to the right is
starting to flatten out a little bit and
i would still consider that you know
maybe acceptable for sale but once it
gets to the image on the right which is
what i call pancake
that's something that i would not
consider selling to my customers but is
perfectly fine to consume
yourself
all right and i did mention some pests
and while this list might seem like
there's um
a lot of potential pests that really the
main one that i hear most growers and
you know myself i have issues with are
slugs
um so slugs really like to eat
mushrooms and in your laying yard it's
this high moisture managed scenario
where slugs can
really start to take over so you can do
some things to reduce those impacts and
i think the best cure which i've
highlighted here is to harvest quickly
don't let those mushrooms just sit on
the logs if they're ready to be taken
off
um and then
in terms of reducing the slug population
you can
rake or remove some of the leaf duff
that's below your logs so you kind of
remove that habitat
you can elevate your logs off the ground
so the butts of those logs are not in
contact with the soil
and i've seen a lot of interesting
solutions using things like tarpon or
copper wire and um i think any any
effort makes a big difference there
um in terms of these other pests like i
mentioned if you don't wax the holes
over slugs or rodents might want to
consume that mycelium but i haven't seen
much impacts on the mushroom itself
except for
one grower that i've heard has a deer
that's taken a liking to his shiitakes
and kind of keeps coming back
but besides that one instance i haven't
heard much
impacts from deer pressure
and then after they're harvested you can
store them in breathable bags in their
refrigerator um they'll keep for quite
some time
there are drying options for long
storage
if you are looking to sell they cannot
be dry the way i have them here on my
picnic table and they do need to be
processed in a commercial kitchen
and like any mushroom they need to be
cooked before you eat them
in terms of scaling production
you know like a lot of crops you can
start small so you can have just a few
bolts kind of get a handle on the
process and if it's something that you
enjoy doing you can start to scale up to
meet your production needs
um the main piece with this is that you
have to wait a full year for that
incubation period so it does take you
know a bit of planning ahead
and you can see here um with some
scalable pictures the bottom is you know
soaking in those tanks like i have and
the top is using a pond where you can
really do a high volume just not sure
exactly how we got them out
and so shiitakes grown on logs are
really a specialty crop um
they can be advertised using like that
timber stand improvement piece as a real
strong marketing piece
and they're sold at about 10 to 16 per
pound uh 10 is more of the wholesale
and 16 is more of the retail i have a
picture here of some advertising that i
did for my home production where
i generally sell them for fourteen
dollars a pound
and steve gabriel did some great work
through a new york phone viability
project for enterprise planning
and
documented and found through some
research that about a thousand long
operation will net ten thousand dollars
annually
so people that are thinking about like a
larger scale commercial production
generally try to reach that number of a
thousand logs um but along with that
work um through the farm viability
project came some great development of
um like budgeting and marketing and a
lot of supporting materials to help
navigate that
there are a few voluntary certification
programs i don't see many growers
interacting with them but there's just a
general certified organic and also
certified naturally grown
and so while shiitakes should be the
center crop because of their reliability
throughout the season once you establish
a mushroom
production and have clients it makes
sense to start looping in other
other mushrooms that can't be
forced to fruit as reliably so when they
flush you can just add them into the mix
and hopefully sell them through those
same avenues on the left here we have
golden oysters that are being fruited on
a downed aspen with wedges that were cut
out and then packed with spawn
in the center we have wine cap
stropharia which grows
out of
wood chips and soil
and on the right there's a beautiful
lion's mane fruiting off of a beach in a
totem stack so a vertical log with a
cookie cut off packed with spawn put
back on and incubated for a year or two
okay and there's just a couple resources
just our our website at cce columbia
green my woodlot's a local entity that
houses some great uh woodland resources
cornell small farms and then the bottom
is the best management practices for oh
there's a typo for log base shiitake
cultivation which is a phenomenal
resource
and thanks for listening
thank you so much tracy for that
incredibly detailed tour through
um
growing mushrooms
really fantastic we had a couple
questions
in the chat one is about
nutrition and um the person asked if the
if waiting to harvest so when you maybe
get towards that pancake stage is there
do we know anything about any change in
the nutritional quality of the mushrooms
not to my knowledge i believe that they
would still have the same nutrition in
the mushroom
but i wonder with the flavor reducing i
think i think that they themselves just
start to decay
all the same components are still there
right okay
and there's another really fascinating
question about possible use of invasive
trees and if if there's been any
models for growing mushrooms on um
ailanthus trees or a tree of heaven
yeah so at first with emerald ash borer
coming through everyone was trying to
grow different mushrooms on ash trees
without a lot of great success and i am
not sure about ailanthus
don't have an answer to that not to my
knowledge but i would love to hear if
someone's found success with that
yes we need more research and i see the
other question is about ash so there we
go
okay and also i don't know if you can
speak real really briefly about just um
shiitake nutrition in general but the
as as far as a food source
some of the highlights of their
nutritional components
sure yeah they have a lot of
micronutrients i'm not much of a
nutritionist myself but um like many
mushrooms they're pretty high in
proteins um
not as high as animal proteins but more
comparable to uh like nuts
so mainly um they're used for a protein
supplement
wonderful thank you
awesome thanks samantha
yeah like like samantha just said we
grow wild simulated ginseng we also grow
shiitake mushrooms and we put
implemented a small alley cropping
system which is still in its infancy
but we're utilizing a bunch of the
different agroforestry techniques that
were talked about today but for now for
today we're going to focus on wild
simulated ginseng so and because we've
only got 20 minutes i think i'm going to
kind of take the lead on the
presentation and justin's going to jump
in as needed so just a little background
um
i did my undergraduate at cornell
university and in the natural resources
program i learned about agroforestry and
got really interested in
uh the possibilities of it and i was
lucky enough to be able to apprentice
with bob beifus after i graduated and
he's a retired extension agent who
specializes in
american ginseng both wild harvest and
on the wild simulated uh growing system
and i got roped in very quickly to
managing american ginseng farm
which
throughout the hudson valley and
catskills we've planted at this point
over 250 acres of wild simulated ginseng
so really taking what is primarily a
backyard
scale production and going real big real
quick um and
that's how i met justin and we got to
know each other and now we have our own
business wild hudson valley where we
primarily teach about forest farming and
about the environmental and human
history of the hudson valley so we're
kind of presenting in that capacity
today
though our our involvement with ginseng
is primarily with american ginseng farm
so just to start off what is ginseng
it's a small herbaceous plant that grows
in the forest understory it's native to
north america and it prefers
cool shady moist
generally sloped areas but that's not a
rule
it grows
all throughout
new york state and
uh
i'll get into more of the background so
the scientific name for ginseng is
panics pinkifolias if you recognize
panax comes from panacea you know in
greek meaning all healing and that's all
and ginseng is primarily grown as a
medicinal herb it's not a food crop um
and
it's closely related to asian ginseng
which has been grown uh
or which has been used in chinese
medicine for over two thousand years and
when it was discovered by europeans that
uh a sister species to asian ginseng
grew in north america in the early 1700s
uh trade with east asia quickly
developed um but ginseng had been used
and is still used by native peoples in
of northeastern native peoples and i'll
let justin chime in quickly just to talk
about that a little bit well this i mean
we could do a whole presentation on that
topic we actually wrote a paper for a
smithsonian a while back on it that
that's a long story but yeah that's just
a little just a cool little fact before
we continue on but um a lot of people
don't realize that when the american
ginseng trade started
um it was primarily
um the roots were primarily dug and
traded by native people in the northeast
and then in the south later in the 18th
century um and it
was a huge economic
um it was hugely of economic importance
for native people here throughout the
first half of the 18th century and
second half during a time when they were
you know
there were a lot of wars going on the
french indian more than the revolution
um so it's kind of a cool side thing
that a lot of people don't know about
was a native role in that trade anyway
yeah so ginseng has had a long history
of being harvested uh why in the wild
over the last 300 years and at this
point
because of that over harvesting for
centuries
it's pretty limited but it does grow all
throughout
the appalachian mountain range and
generally in this area
so ginseng is has a very complicated
life cycle that's really important to
understand when you're thinking about
growing it so starting with the upper
left we have ginseng seeds uh which are
about the size of a lentil and when a
seed ripe when a berry ripens that
contains
one to three seeds on a plant that seed
actually remains dormant in the soil for
18 months on average and throughout that
time the embryo inside the hard seed is
living and breathing so it's not
a plant like you know where you take
squash seeds and dry them and keep it in
a packet in your house they don't store
that way in fact
if the seed dries out for more than a
few weeks um the embryo will shrivel up
and die so it's a finicky plant right
from the start but the first year that
center
top picture that's a ginseng seedling
and that's the way it's going to look
for its whole first year of growth just
three little leaflets um kind of looks
like a little strawberry
leaf on it's very serrated you can see
it's got these little hairs on the veins
which is a great way to identify ginseng
compared to some of its look-alikes um
then after the first few years it may
start to get two leaves like the picture
on the top right those are two
individual leaves one of them has three
leaflets and one has five leaflets
but you're looking at five years until
it looks like that bottom right picture
that's in good condition which i believe
are tracy tesla's hands because tracy
actually helped us on the ginseng farm
for a few years a number of years ago
and uh
so when you get these three leaflet or
three leaved plants uh generally it's
five years or older in the wild
and in the wild ginseng might not
actually replace itself in the wild
until it's 10 years old so that's one of
the main reasons why it's so easy to
over harvest ginseng is because it's
it's not going to produce a viable
offspring for potentially 10 or more
years but once it gets much older it
might have four leaves sometimes five or
six but that's very rare and it produces
uh berries in the fall which normally
contain about two seeds and it starts
all over again
so you can actually age a ginseng plant
by counting the scars on the rhizome of
the plant so every year the the base of
the stem will leave a flat scar and then
the next year stem will grow out and
they stack on top of each other
and you can see this plant here was 25
years old when it was harvested and that
root is like barely the size of a ruler
so you can see how small these plants
really are and why they fetch such a
high value per pound you're looking at a
fairly small
harvest for a very
uh valuable route so
um
internationally ginseng is listed under
appendix ii of the cities treaty which
mean and it's a species of special
concern so it's not actually listed as
threatened or endangered but it's like
it's on a watch list
and because of that ginseng is regulated
uh
by all 17 states in which in the united
states in which it grows in new york
state for example there's a ginseng
hunting season just like deer hunting
season you can't harvest ginseng until
september 1st to the end of november and
the plants have to be five years old and
they're you know it's it's highly
regulated in terms of
how you can buy and sell the plant and
bringing it across state and federal
borders you need like a certificate so
it's something to consider if you're
thinking about growing ginseng because
unfortunately
it's hard to tell the difference between
a wild ginseng
root and a cultivated ginseng root so
they're actually regular well that
depends on the method of cultivation
well yes but it's regulated the same no
matter what unless you can sort of prove
that you're growing ginseng and there
are third-party verification systems
which have been set up just in the last
few years
united plant savers does a forest grown
certification that's specifically for
ginseng where they'll come and verify
that you're growing ginseng so if if
you're thinking about planting a sizable
uh you know a few acres of
ginseng or more you may want to consider
getting a third party verification so
that you can prove you're growing it so
that it's not going to be regulated as
if it was wild in that in that same way
so today 90 of american ginseng on the
market is actually grown underneath the
shade cloth as you can imagine the plant
is scattered here and there throughout
the forest and
very early on
people were experimenting with how to
grow it in a more conventional farming
system and this is what has been
developed since the late 1800s it used
to be wooden lattice structures that
ginseng was being grown under now it's a
70 shade cloth and in this system you
can see you can grow a lot of ginseng in
a very small space but the problem is
that ginseng is not happy growing there
it's
so different from the way that it grows
in the wild that it becomes very
susceptible to primarily fungal
pathogens you're looking at like
altenaria and phytophthora root rot um
and so in these systems you have to
spray generally on a two week basis both
pesticides and fungicides and even then
the ginseng plants themselves rarely
survive more than three or four years
once you pass that fourth year
uh the plant you start to lose so many
plants to disease that it's better to
just harvest it so you can imagine in
the wild you're not harvesting these
plants until they're at least five years
old or older so it's a very different
style of production and there's
unfortunately no way that this
production can be organic so wild
simulated or woods any woods grown
production provides like a
slightly less risky way that where
you'll fetch a higher value so looking
at this picture on the left um those are
field-grown routes that are about three
to four years old that's maybe sixty
dollars worth of roots on the right
you're looking at wild simulated roots
which if you look at those longer necks
they're 10 years older or more and it's
you know over 10 times the uh
value and
per root
um
so
um when you're looking at woods
cultivated and wild stimulated those are
the two woodland production systems and
only a small amount of the ginseng on
the market today comes from these
systems woods cultivated is using the
forest canopy to
create shade but other than that it's
very similar to the shade gloss class
system you are tilling and amending the
soil and you have very like dense
planting rates and you generally have to
spray and
in the same way that you do with a
cultivated a more cultivated system but
you have the potential for big harvests
what i focus on is wild simulated jim
saying so that's finding these ideal
conditions in which ginseng would
naturally thrive and in many cases
you're growing
ginseng right alongside wild ginseng um
and in this way you're all you're
you're using conservation through
cultivation so because wild simulated
plants are basically indistinguishable
from wild ginseng
they can replace well ginseng in the
marketplace and protect some of these uh
you know more disjointed wild
populations from
harvest but it's a long-term investment
um but in our feeling it's worth it
so i'm gonna go a little bit into how to
select areas for ginseng how to plant
them how to steward them and how to
eventually harvest them but i've only
got like 10 minutes so it's it's going
to be quick so you're looking at old
mature woods
generally dominated by sugar maples but
basswood trees butternut white ash
sometimes yellow birch
even hemlet hemlocks tulip trees
in some parts of the state are all great
over
species
there's ginseng has a reputation of
growing on the north and east facing
slopes that's not a rule it's just that
north and east facing slopes tend to
have the cool moist habitat in which
ginseng really thrives whereas when you
get to the south and west facing size of
slopes you the hot afternoon sun tends
to lead to a more dry environment and
you get more oh hickory dominated
over stories so it's not a rule but
generally north and east facing slopes
are where you'll where you tend to find
ginseng habitat
um you you know areas where it's a lot
of conifers
uh pines aspen birch and invasive
species are not great areas to grow
ginseng and with wild stimulated ginseng
you really want to be looking for that
ideal habitat and doing as little
amendment as you can because it's a low
input system where you're not going to
be
tilling or amending the soil or changing
that environment very much
we do recommend doing soil testing
you're going to look at the calcium
magnesium and the organic matter you see
on the picture on the top right this
like black beautiful rich soil um is
really what you're looking for
for ginseng to thrive in but the last
consideration when you're deciding where
to plant your ginseng is proximity to
your house or
an area that you can monitor easily
because um security is a concern
uh
you know ginseng hunting has been
something that people have been doing
for hundreds of years and still do
and unfortunately even though it's not
legal to hunt on private land without
permission from the landowner
people do it and uh
you know
it only takes one year out of the 10
years or plus years you're growing
ginseng for someone to come through and
wipe it out so thinking about security
is is an important part i just said one
thing
so there just to take a step back on the
soil
um there are thousands if not millions
of acres of sugar maple dominated forest
in new york in the northeast that are
not great for growing ginseng even
though it loves sugar maple trees and
that's because that forest is you know
second third fourth growth that was
pasture there's a big difference between
that hard soil low in organic matter and
basically the old growth type soil that
ginseng really thrives in and you're
looking you're probably gonna have to
amend that kind of you know
lower organic matter newer soil that
under young younger sugar maple forest
if that's what you have
so the one great way to
fine tune an area to plant within your
property is to look for what are called
indicator plants so plants that have a
similar habitat uh requirements to
ginseng in this picture we have
maidenhair fern rattlesnake fern blue
cohosh um
amongst other species and finding a
combination of these plants will will
really tell you that you're planting in
the right place i'm not going to go into
this too much but
justin actually did write a book on a
field guide to finding ginseng habitat
which we have available on our website
what we recommend people do the first
year when they're thinking of starting
to grow ginseng is to plant test plots
so that might be a three by three area
or five by five area maybe something a
little bigger and you choose a number of
these areas throughout your property and
what you think are the best areas and
you just plant a handful of ginseng
seeds in each place
and see how it does so you're going to
be doing your planting in the fall and
then ginseng germinates in the spring
and if you follow your ginseng
throughout that first growing season or
even a second growing season you'll get
an idea for where the ginseng is going
to do
better and where it's going to do poorly
and where you can expand upon your
plantings because it's such a long-term
investment planting in the wrong place
can really like
mess things up after a few years
and just
don't get too excited if you have really
good germination that first year because
ginseng will germinate anywhere it'll
germinate in your refrigerator and a wet
toilet paper roll or in a sandbox and
survive for weeks sometimes months you
really got to give it a few years this
plant takes a lot of patience yes
um instead so when you uh purchase seed
generally seed
always comes from these uh shade cloth
grown operations which isn't inherently
a problem
um
because it's a wild ginseng seed or wild
simulated ginseng seed as far as we know
is not available anywhere on the market
uh wild ginseng seed it's actually not
legal to sell seed from because it's
listed as a species of concern and
as a steward you should plant the
ginseng seeds back near the
rest of the population and not
extract that from the woods you want to
keep the population going so like i said
earlier you need to keep the seeds
hydrated um and we aim to plant about
five seeds per square foot so that's
four to six inch spacing if you look at
the picture on the top right you'll see
these little red dots scattered around
we actually uh dye our ginseng seed or
red colors when we're planting acres at
a time so that we can toss this seed out
and see where it's landing a lot easier
than when it's tan colored so but that
gives you an idea of the kind of spacing
that you're looking at you don't want to
plant ginseng too thick because uh of
the potential for fungal pathogens to
come in the the more spread out plants
are the less disease will spread through
a population
but generally it's pretty
straightforward you rake back the leaf
litter broadcast the seeds on the soil
surface sometimes um you can stamp on
like i would recommend like kind of
stomping on them to make sure that they
have a contact with the soil some people
will actually bury the seeds a little
bit
i would never bury them more than an
inch deep because that little seedling
has to wind its way
up through leaf litter and it needs all
the help it can get
as long as your seeds are in contact
with the soil you're you're good to go
and then make sure to cover the seeds
back up with the leaves
in most cases you can put the same
leaves that you just took off right back
on and make sure that it's a good
two to four inch layer because you don't
want your ginseng seeds to dry out
because they're exposed to the elements
and also because ginseng seed that's
covered uh by leaves will be a lot more
protected from chipmunks or other
squirrels that are out like eating seeds
and foraging in the fall and mice
and turkeys yep and make sure to mark
where you plan so many times i talk to
people and they're like oh yeah i
planted some ginseng a few years ago but
i was never able to find it
um
so use surveyor flags like in that
bottom picture or somehow mark the trees
around the perimeter of where you're
planting um
so that you can find it because those
little tiny seedlings that stick up
maybe an inch from the soil you're it's
they're really hard to find amongst all
those other companion plants that we
talked about so one thing to keep in
mind with ginseng is you don't want to
weed it like you would in a in a garden
bed um the more it's growing amongst the
other species that it's used to growing
in in the wild the better
you don't want to create a situation
where it's just this monoculture of of
ginseng plants because then you'll have
more disease problems down the road
so your ginseng seeds will come up may
to early june you don't want to
have
uh
you're generally not going to have a
very great germination rate because
you're not even tilling or amending the
soil in this case
and you you're scattering the seeds
potentially some are landing on rocks
and you only really care to have about
one plant per square foot or one or even
every two three feet by the time the
plants get to be of an adult age because
again that those fungal pathogens
that'll come in if you end up with an
area that's too thick like that bottom
right picture those are just like
there's probably a hundred seedlings in
that like three square foot or
nine square foot area
um you can thin them out we recommend
waiting until year three because the
little tiny roots that the plants form
in that first year uh are not they don't
have a great uh transplant success rate
i would i would wait till year three
you'll you'll have at least like an 80
transplant success rate
at that point and some people do sell
ginseng transplants
and that's something you can purchase if
you're interested in just in having some
ginseng on your property
but in terms of if you're going to have
a commercial ginseng operation it's much
more worth your time to start from seed
in terms of that initial investment and
keeping costs low
so maintenance the great thing about
wild stimulated ginseng is that after
your you plant it you're really just
sort of standing back and watching it
grow you of course need to keep to make
monitor for disease and pests but if
you've followed what we just said about
planting uh
about planting properly you aren't
generally going to have a huge problem
with with those uh
uh pests so
um and then on the picture on the right
you know making sure you have signage to
keep people out and game cameras in the
woods is always are always really
helpful um one thing justin just
whispered to me is uh
making sure uh one thing you can do to
keep
uh
other animals from getting to your
ginseng turkeys plants are to make or to
put some brush down after you put the
leaf litter back down putting down some
brush so that
there's
it holds the leaf litter down and also
makes it harder for deer and other
animals to eat your ginseng leaves
because unfortunately ginseng
deer love ginseng so this is sort of a
reality check dear like to eat ginseng
so if you're growing a smaller amount of
ginseng you can fence in an area but if
you're going larger scale and planting a
few acres
fencing becomes
you know
more
expensive and it may be
and it may and yes and it may be easier
just to control the deer population
through hunting um slugs will eat
ginseng foil it
foliage and ginseng will also get eaten
by other little insects it's we see that
every year on our plants the great thing
about ginseng being a perennial plant is
that
if for some reason the top of the plant
is uh
is cut off in one year the root will
often have enough like
energy reserves to produce a top that
the next year even though it was eaten
so if if a ginseng plant disappears one
year it may come back a year or two
later um we've sometimes seen
ginseng plants be dormant for like three
four years and then come up and they're
fine
um it's a very interesting plant to
watch uh in the wild
and
when your plants do start to produce
seeds if you want to try to replant
those seeds you have to be careful for
rodents um chipmunks that that the
chipmunk there all those seeds were
inside its little cheeks at one given
time so something to consider
um when it comes to harvesting again you
want to wait until they're at least five
years old
because that's when it's legal the
hunting season starts september 1st but
i recommend waiting until they're 10
years old or even older 25 year old
ginseng is going to be worth way more
than a five-year-old plant you can see
from these two pictures
and
uh it's
in my mind it's it's definitely worth
waiting until your roots have a lot more
character one thing to keep in mind is
that because
most ginseng is ending up being sold on
the east asian market as medicine
uh
the
historic like traditionally the way that
ginseng is valued is through its
physical appearance and there are like
over a dozen different ways to grade
ginseng into different levels um and
you know from a western mindset we might
be like oh well the
chemical
like structure is going to be the same
in terms of the medicine whether it's a
young plant or an older plant
but the value
is way higher if you can wait and until
there they have a lot of older character
um also improper harvesting can just
ruin the value of your of your plant so
you want to make sure that you're not
breaking it that you're getting all the
root hairs when you're harvesting it and
once you're at the point where you're
harvesting ginseng you're probably going
to be working with a buyer and they'll
offer you a lot of guidance and specify
how they want their roots do they want
them fresh they want them dried and if
they want them dried how do they
how do they want them to be dried so
this is my last slide about drying roots
um you want to lightly wash the dirt off
them but you don't want to be scrubbing
them clean um having dirt in
in the
wrinkles on the root um is great and so
really you just want to be hitting them
with a steady stream of water or
swishing them around in like a basin of
water to get the excess dirt off they
don't need to be scrub clean it's better
that they're not that's doing that as a
way to like completely destroy the value
of your roux and then you want to dry
them slowly never dry them in an oven
dry them
at a little warmer than room temperature
a warm attic works great spread them out
on a single layer and properly dried
roots will store indefinitely so that
gives you some wiggle room in terms of
when you go to sell them as an end
product
so that was like a really fast intro um
if anyone has any questions feel free to
reach out to us
that's our email right there
and uh yeah one thing yes i'm sorry i
know this is probably running late but
one thing i don't know if we mentioned
it but we've learned this
as have other growers i'm sure over the
years um
through experience that you really want
to mimic natural canopy disturbances and
i think this is probably true of any
northeastern forest farmed crops
especially natives if you want a good
yield and healthy plants that don't grow
at a snail's pace you do want to mimic
natural canopy disturbance that means
doing some minor thinning of your forest
that might just be branches it might be
sick trees it might be you know certain
species so that you could
increase the balance and enrich species
diversity but by doing that and bringing
in that little bit of extra light um you
are going to see a huge difference like
i can't tell you how often we've seen
wild stimulated ginseng plantings that
we're not where the forest was not
thinned and because of the shade
seven eight-year-old plants looked like
they were two years old so that's it on
my last little thing
all right
fantastic thank you so much um what an
interesting and fascinating um plant
that you all have been really building
such a detailed
relationship with i can really tell how
much care and expertise you bring to
ginseng
cultivation
um someone in the chat brett chedsoy in
particular also wanted to offer i think
an extension of
your use of brush this uh something
called slash walls which i imagine are
brush piles but built big
and so perhaps you've used those but
that's another way to use the natural
resources you have around you
to help protect these high-value
crops and apparently very delicious
crops to many creatures
anyone else have any oh okay so someone
uh michael rosado's asking if you have
any perf if you can list any
particularly preferred ginseng seed
suppliers
or where we can find that
yeah and that's something i didn't get
into because this is such a short
presentation um but
there are many ways to kill ginseng seed
um
and so making sure that you're working
with a supplier and not just getting
plants on like ebay or etsy uh is
is we highly recommend
we work with particular growers in
ontario and if you want to uh contact us
we can
help you get in touch with them um but
we buy pre-stratified seeds i see jeff
is chiming and asking about that so the
growers where hu will harvest the seeds
uh in one fall and then store them
throughout that first winter and into
the following spring
they actually
completely dry them out at that point
because they they're still
relatively dormant they keep them in
cold stratification and then what needs
to happen is that embryo needs to spend
about three months of a warm period
expanding and so it fills out the shell
and then sometimes it actually cracks
open the shell a little bit and that's
called smiling seed and that's really
great um and if you that happens by the
following fall which is when
we would be planting it for germination
the next spring so we're buying sea
that's already pre-stratified it's had
that first uh
dormant season
and
uh we work with these growers in ontario
we actually sell seed so
uh that's where we get our seeds yeah we
warm strata we do the final worm
stratification
ourselves because it really makes a
difference in the next year's
germination yeah what we do is we store
the seed in sand on our farm uh where
it's in dappled sunlight so it's it's
getting its
naturally warm period for about a few
months before we plant it um and we keep
it in
an area where
in where it's not going to get fungal
pathogens as easily in the sand so that
makes sense yeah we sterilize it um
what else was there anything else on the
seeds i'm trying to there's
there's something that's oh yeah a lot
of people are always looking for wild
simulated seed
um
i could tell you again from you know
since we've planted like
multiple hundred acres i don't think
it's possible to viably
uh
grow wild some agents and for seed
production
it would be extremely labor-intensive it
is very possible but the seed would be
as practically as expensive as the roots
probably just because it would be so
labor intensive to harvest them
some all the seed on the market pretty
much is coming from shade cloth you know
field growers um i don't really think
there's a way around it the cool thing
is ginseng seed has been grown
has been collected from around the
eastern north american continent and
collected for a century and a half at
the very least and studies have shown
that the genetics of the seed its
parentage is coming from everywhere i
mean you'll find genetics and seed from
ontario there'll be genetics from
wisconsin and north carolina and the
northeast so you're getting like super
seed in a sense hybrid vigor yeah
awesome thank you
yeah but other of the presenters want to
put your contact information in the chat
in case other people would like to reach
out to you
i'd always like to
give all of our presenters a huge uh
warm
round of applause thank you so much all
of you are incredible experts it's
really clear how much
how much time and expertise that you
have built around this it's really
incredible the the the wealth of
knowledge and experience that we have
and we have covered such an amazing
diversity of
cropping systems and plant types and
agroforestry systems
really and we've only really just
scratched the surface on the potential
of agroforestry in the northeast so it's
really exciting i hope to see
interest and events like this grow in
the further
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu